[Music]
I'm here for Hasbro's new toy don't lose
your cool don't lose your cool it's a
fun party game where you and your
friends can get together and torture
each other until this meter blinks red
and then when you do and your friends
stress and hates you win who wins
do you wonder the people is the
objective to get to the top where is the
objective don't lose your cool mom Larry
mom mom Larry is our mom Larry what
we're gonna be doing I guess actually
unboxing Hey there it is now it's
important to remember batteries are not
included in this and as far as I know it
is required to calibrate it so I'm gonna
I'm gonna do that and it's important
when you're calibrating it to think very
calm thoughts okay
[Music]
it's important to stay still but I've
never been more stressed in my entire
life I think my brain has been uploaded
to Hasbro's database okay
what's happened how could I lose I was
already so stressed okay so that didn't
work but I wasn't even playing game so
in order to play this game I'd like to
introduce my two friends you remember us
in Vegas right okay all right so I don't
know if I need to recalibrate it I
really hope I don't you are using the
dice of the box right sorry
what is the dice can you unbox these for
me yes princess box piranha
you get some dye what do you have to do
laughs a lot sniff them and close to you
were too stressed what were you thinking
about
Oh singing of cheap Brown how much I
loved her love shouldn't stress you out
that much guys I'm under a lot of
pressure I'm a youtuber you know yeah we
have stressed lives once you go next
okay unbox yours Oh a box it on camera
you dingus columns are Vegas hey guys
can you don't lose your cool here take
it out of the box
there's the dice you're ready plates a
real plugin our batteries included no
don't even think for a second that
they're included anymore godbye and
severed they're not included we'll do a
little tutorial step by step first take
the strap off put it on your head
remember apply your headrest first
before helping others now make sure
rests right in the middle of your
forehead that's where the stress levels
are metered press the button
[Music]
no not like this
Tyler unbox yours
alright guys I've got this this awesome
new game from Hasbro don't lose your
cool Wow yeah it's it's a great game
we're gonna we're gonna play together
this tonight it doesn't come with
something no it doesn't come with
batteries okay
could it not are definitely not included
you have to go buy those separately buy
your batteries
[Music]
I have an idea if we all wear them and
then the first one to go loses all right
the beanbag over here some of the stress
relieving these powerful beanbag it was
a lot heavier that so we go on three on
three like when you say three when one
two three go or one two three go okay
what about three two one go
three no you count three two you count
one two three I'll count three do you
want what mister isn't a lot you've
never felt the pain
[Music]
did you calibrate me because my head is
just so misshapen Lee huge that it
didn't it wasn't pressing Oh is there
hair in the way okay let's try that
again what I don't like died already
what okay so we're obviously not doing
this right I think I know we obviously
are not doing it right
there's a piece of paper hey you
audience go downstairs and find it go go
good boy or girl good day good Chi G
good human being them
[Music]
if
well that would make okay actually that
makes sense because if it was over on
the temple it would have a better
reading oh that's why I was one but that
makes no one tries to help me here good
okay so we're finally figuring out all
right so because as bro probably wants
one round of actual using it I'm gonna
try it again
oh yeah we're supposed to try and stress
each other
[Music]
okay you know how you take a temperature
by sticking it under your tongue I'm so
hard cuz I had to press with my tongue
but I think I think that is it just has
to get a good heartbeat yeah why is in
your title time it's dying these guys
had a revelation I'm not at peace with
it no if weird if it's too tight
food squeeze the blood out and it
wouldn't get a heart rate so maybe we're
too tight okay wait
we should be standing why because if you
stand you squeeze the muscles in your
legs
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay I have an idea we have to simulate
a heartbeat
[Music]
[Laughter]
your dandelion recipe blown about his
last hopes and dreams mr. no heart okay
so now that we've figured it out get
ready for another hour of playing the
game those dice up guys
I'll start the calibration I've got one
I've got three
focuses Rollem problem quick be a robot
slow motion seems like you're pretty
damn stressed this is your life okay I
think I lost and I think that was the
closest to a normal game that we could
possibly get
dingus is dirt you unser all this time
yes three two one
state wait that's weakness sniff them
fart noises and fart fart fart fart fart
flatulence big stinky poopy fart
accidentally filling your pants with
fart we have good smiling deodorant know
whether it's a poop or a fart so that
you do man thinking about Michael Cera
the whole time and he really just
calming down Michael Cera in the end of
the world or any version this almost
feels like an interrogation or something
to confess
[Music]
the pig the pig is coming to the piggies
all right so this is been don't lose
your cool we didn't not a single time
none of us shut up
none of us lost what there's one more
control that we need get out of the way
witness since its October October is the
time of scuba CH I thought it would be
prudent dig up mom's old carcass yeah
mom okay mom okay all right mom it's
time to tell the truth for one for one
[Music]
[Applause]